absolutely Sam welcome back to the show
uh great victory for you with the black
pieces this was not an easy game there
was a lot of pressure out of the opening
your structure wasn't looking right
there's that Knight on F5 swarming
around your king tell us the story of
this game uh from your perspective yeah
well it was sort of funny that I just
think I really outplayed my opponents
the previous two days and just somehow
they defended right when the time came
and I didn't manage to get put points on
the board but then the one game where
I'm supposed to get crushed is where I
win so uh yeah I mean I think Hans
prepared better than me I I somehow
fudged the move order and I had prepared
something with where he had played H3
but some the the line that I had chosen
to play H3 is strictly a wasted Tempo I
probably should have done a different
move while were prepared more carefully
and I think very quickly I was just
worse but the big move that I think I
mean when he played Knight F5 back to E3
I would just couldn't believe my I mean
I get it he wants to stop Knight C4
bring the other Knight to F5 and just
dribble the ball into the goal but it
just felt like such a backwards move and
then once I got Queen G5 H5 once I
played Queen G5 I thought he absolutely
should have played G3 and then it gets
quite messy after H5 Knight G2 I don't
know if you have the board yes yes we do
have the board there was this moment in
fact after the move H knight3 I was very
surprised did you spot this idea of
f4 um saw it right after I moved but it
didn't scare me very much what's the
point after Knight takes F4 Knight takes
F4
H4 and then Queen like F6 or whatever am
I just busted after or something or Rook
F1 okay and here am I just lost yes yeah
oh that's bad so F4 is a winner F4 is
winning on the spot but it's very
difficult to play right I mean very
difficult to understand why that's
that's an incredibly hard move see I had
I had seen H4 and then F4 that doesn't
work even or come even close and here if
I take with the queen he just goes Queen
H5 or something Queen takes H5 yes and
is this that yeah okay yeah plus yeah
yeah know my my my Queen's trapped
that's the problem yeah okay yeah so I
guess we both just missed this after
Queen G5 I was instead of after Queen G5
here like already I thought I was doing
totally fine I mean I was expecting him
with Knight df5 necessary I I thought
after Queen G5 was Knight df5 the best
move I guess if he's got this uh this F4
it works cuz I was expecting I was
actually curious about the line here
G3 uh if he plays G3 instead of Knight
F5 I want it to go H5 and then Knight G2
and this one was uh very interesting to
me because F4 is coming I thought I have
to play Knight C4 mhm uh otherwise I'm
dead on the spot and I was trying to
figure out what was going on after H4
now and it just seemed very complicated
I couldn't quite make it work like Queen
G4 and it felt wrong somehow Queen C1
maybe it's holding together for black
but I was worried but once you let me
get my Pawn to H4 and the Knight to F4 I
mean I know my my queen side structure
is sort of deficient but I was already
thinking I can play for an advantage and
very nicely spotted because indeed you
you right now have the advantage after
this move Knight to
four yeah uh and I don't know if I was
the cleanest but I I did decline the
repetition when I had you know three
minutes against 20 or something and yeah
so here yeah for a good reason this is
just bad news for white yeah and then
yeah he just can't do a thing about the
attack and then yeah now he's dead very
professionally made the 40th move Knight
D5 Knight F4 calculated everything and
then took yeah I saw Knight takes F3 I I
saw Knight takes F3 wins the move on
move 39 but I just thought I might as
well repeat once he's not going Rook F2
so why do I care um but yeah uh no it's
funny that I mean the last two days were
just so frustrating and today just
totally outplayed and I should have been
crushed and that's the game I won so you
know chess works like that sometimes
even at a very high level guys any
questions for uh no congratulations uh
Sam and uh nicely spotted that whole
Knight F3 uh for for us as well I just
want to emphasize the move F4 is like
it's freakish because everything that
you were doing just made natural Good
Sense Queen G5 H5 H4 Knight F4 and the
fact that white had this move F4 was a
real shock for me he's like what well I
mean even even considering Hans missed
that I think he should have just been
much better easily if he hadn't brought
like the Knight back to E3 like I think
I'm just much worse either way there so
uh yeah I guess he was clearly better
and mystically win but I took my chance
when it came congratulations Sam
absolutely thank you as uh several